I suppose I'm an opinion maker.
I publish a lot.
I give a lot of speeches.
Uh,
I try to analyze things,
provide leadership.
I don't do it within an organization.
The university has been a base for me to
do it to the outside.
I spend a lot of time abroad.
I think it's very important for
Americans to do that now because our
role in the world is so confused at this
point in time.
So I think,
uh,
by writing and teaching,
I'm an opinion makers.
I think they're very important.
I've,
I'm a generalist in a world is full of
specialist.
I'm a generalist.
I've caught in a number of different
disciplines.
I know a great deal about a lot of
subjects.
Uh,
I have tried to focus on big questions
in the sub.
I've tried intentionally to be a
generalist and that's unusual in the
modern world and a lot of people are
very suspicious of that,
but I think it's very important for
somebody to try to figure out how the
whole thing fits together.
And I think the lack of that is a real
problem that we have.
So I think the most important thing I've
done is to try to be a generalist and to
provide some leadership and some
perspective in that.